If you want to challenge me to do some Dares
in a future video, stick around for the entirety
video to find out how.
Why have you taken me to this creepy place?
This is your apartment!
Oh yeah right.
So why are we playing Truth or Dare though?
For views.
Ok, good enough for me.
So what will it be then?
Truth or Dare?
Dare obviously.
I dare you, to find me 19 Things You Missed
in the new movie Truth or Dare.
I mean...
I was gonna do that anyway.
Many of the first things you missed stem from
the first Truths and Dares when Carter / Sam
takes them to the mission to trick them into
joining the game.
I'll come back to Olivia's truth question
later in this video because it leads into
a bigger point I that want to make.
But many of the questions that the friends
ask each other are teasers into the cause
of their untimely deaths.
For example, Ronnie is challenged to lap dance
a guy, and we he his hesitation to do a dare
that makes him look bad.
Later on, at the pub when Calyx is one daring
him, his hesitation leads to his own demise.
Lucas's dare is to go nude in front of everyone,
which represents him making himself sexually
available to more than one person.
He meets his fate when he's unable to choose
which girl he has feelings for.
Then Brad is dared to make out with someone.
He chooses a guy, which sets up his confrontation
with his father who is against homosexuality.
This encounter sets up tension between the
police officer and his son puts the other
cops on high alert about Brad.
In the end, one of the cops pulls the trigger
on him too soon.
Then we've got Tyson who has to tell the truth
about forging prescriptions to freshman.
He's basically asked the same question by
Calyx, only this time it's in front of someone
who's interviewing him.
He lies, and as a result, Calyx makes him
stab himself in the face.
There's been a lot of that in movies lately,
huh?
And the last member of the group is Penelope.
It's not so much the dare that exposes her
weakness here, but the fact that she's super
drunk when she does it.
It's later mentioned that she has a bit of
an issue with day drinking, so her dare shows
her the consequences of alcohol by making
her walk the edge of the roof.
It's important to note that she would have
died here if they didn't catch her, but it
didn't really matter because she ends up getting
shot like 4 minutes later so...
I honestly don't get what the point of that
was.
But the main theme to take away from Penelope
is that she gets drunk all the time and it
causes her to do things she might not normally
do.
I'm also going to talk about how Calyx's game
maybe wasn't entirely a curse and could have
actually been a blessing in disguise and helped
the group, but first let's talk about some
Easter Eggs.
Truth or Dare has a lot in common with another
recent Blumhouse movie, Happy Death Day.
Did anyone notice that the layout of the sorority
house in this movie was the exact same as
the one in Happy Death Day?
Now it could just be that all sorority houses
are laid out like this.
I wouldn't know because I went to art school
and probably wouldn't have been invited to
their parties even if I had gone to a university,
but regardless, I'd say there's a pretty good
chance that they reused that Happy Death Day
set for Truth or Dare.
I also thought that the skull logo seen during
many of the dares that's supposed to represent
Calyx looked a lot like Bughuul from Sinister.
I know Jason Blum has talked recently about
the possibility of a Blumhouse crossover,
so maybe these films take place in the same
universe.
And one more Easter Egg I caught was the character
Carter.
Or I guess his real name is Sam.
There's a good chance he was inspired by Hugh
from the movie It Follows.
The next 20 seconds have spoilers for It Follows.
They both pretend to be interested in the
lead girl in order to get their gaurds down
and trick them into joining the curse, which
really only buys some time until it's their
turn again.
They both use fake names, abandoned locations,
and both go into hiding after passing off
the curse.
Outside of the connections to other movies,
there are also some cool visual references
within the movie.
In the living room there's a giant 6 sided
die.
Not including Carter, who isn't really actually
part of the friend group, there are 6 people
in the group.
And after Ronnie's death, when they are discussing
it the number 5 faces
the camera.
In the med building where Tyson had the interview,
a sign in the background talks about a Whooping
Cough outbreak.
I had to look this up after the movie, but
it's essentially a disease that's highly contagious,
but easily treated with modern medicine.
To me, that's kind of like the truth or dare
game itself.
Highly contagious because it's easy to get
other people involved, but easy to treat if
you have no secrets to hide.
That's one of the reasons I think the game
could be a blessing in a way, rather than
a curse.
All of the truth questions could help make
the character being asked a better person.
And if you've got nothing to hide, you've
got nothing to worry about.
The dares seem to prey on your biggest flaws,
as I've already mentioned, so by making yourself
a better, more honest person you'd be less
prone to dares.
Except for Brad.
He just kind of gets screwed over in the end.
Maybe there's something I'm missing with him,
but he also does kind of prove the point that
the game can improve your life, because when
Calyx forces him to come out of closet to
his father, he actually talks about how good
it felt to finally have that off his chest.
I actually think it would have fit the theme
of the movie better if he has ended up surviving
in the end as an example of someone who improved
their life by putting everything out on the
table.
If you look at any of the characters, they
could have avoided big issues if they had
been more honest with each other.
If Markee wasn't cheating on her boyfriend
she never would have had an issue and the
whole fued with Olivia would have been avoided.
And on the contrary if Lucas was honest that
he wasn't sure about Markee, then he never
would have had to cheat on her with Olivia.
And as a little side note, during that scene,
Markee says she'd rather be anywhere but here
and goes to a little Tortas stand.
So she decides to get Mexican food after the
root of all get problems just started in Mexico.
You think she'd maybe try something else.
And then of course there's the big reveal
about how Olivia was there during Markee's
father's suicide, which is actually kind of
fair because she only kept that from Markee
to protect her and there was no reason to
make her think badly of her deceased Dad.
Overall, Olivia is the most honest and caring
person, so she is able to survive the game,
for now at least.
But there is actually one big lie that Olivia
tells, and it's the thing I mentioned way
at the beginning of the movie.
So they had just had their Spring Break trip,
they don't want the night to end after partying
in Mexico, and this guy Carter leads them
to the abandoned mission to play Truth or
Dare.
Brad is still drunk at the time and asks Olivia
an oddly specific question.
He asks, if Aliens invaded Mexico and she
had to choose between saving the friend group
and saving the rest of Mexico what would she
choose?
Everyone thinks she's going to save the group,
including her best friend.
We are given the idea that she values the
lives of many over her own.
However, at the end of the movie, she is faced
with essentially the same scenario.
She can let her and Markee die, and end the
game once and for all, or she can challenge
the entirety of her YouTube audience and endanger
the lives of her 4.5K subscribers, or let's
face it, with the current state of broken
YouTube notifications, more like 200 people
would actually be in danger.
But still!
She chooses the subscribers!
She makes the selfish choice.
At the beginning of the movie she's this caring
person who wants to build homes for people
and save strangers over herself, but at the
end she does just the opposite.
I don't know if that is a result of her ideals
changing to become more selfish, or if she
was just lying to herself and her friends
at the beginning.
But whatever the answer may be, there's one
thing about this movie that I find disgusting.
The fact that this supposed YouTuber, sells
out her subscribers lives for her own gain.
I may be kind of twisted, but I would NEVER
do that to you people.
First of all, if you kill off your subscribers,
your views are going to go down.
And secondly, you're supposed to treat your
subscribers like royalty, by delivering quality
content and having engaging discussions in
the comments!
You know what?
It's no wonder she only has 4.5K subscribers.
She treats them like crap.
We only see her post once during the course
of this film, which takes place from Spring
Break, which is usually in March or April,
to at least June 7th, which is shown as the
date on Olivia's phone like 3/4th of the way
through the movie.
And then it actually goes past that.
So that's like 3-4 months without posting.
I mean there IS a demon trying to kill her,
but if it was me, I'm just saying I wouldn't
miss an upload.
I mean there's no excuse for this girl to
be that attractive, and not have close to
a million subs.
Your content can literally be terrible if
you look good, and as long as you post often,
you'll make it.
It's been proven time and time again.
The rest of us have to work hard.
And do I sometimes ask you to follow me on
Twitter, Facebook and Instagram?
Yeah.
Do I ask you to like this video if you enjoyed
the content?
Sure.
Do I put links to my merch and ask you to
consider supporting the channel by picking
up one of these cool designs?
Sometimes I do.
But have I ever, done something to put your
life in danger?
No.
And when I say assuming we both survive at
the end of every video, I at least kind of
hope that you actually do, because I do love
seeing your input in the comments.
You know what?
I don't like this Olivia character.
What a bad YouTuber.
Because I actually care about my fans, I'm
going to offer you this.
Leave your own Truths and Dares in the comments
and I'll take the highest rated ones and make
a video answering the truths and doing the
dares.
I have just 3 rules.
I won't do anything illegal.
I won't delete any content.
And I won't spend a bunch of my own money.
In return, my only dare for you is this.
I dare you to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming, we both survive.